ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show from the gas digital studio
in new york city where we're here doing
podcasts
um we did a bunch of stuff this week we
did flagrant
two with andrew schultz we did
the compound show uh what is it called
the compound the compound with josh
brown with josh brown cnbc kind of i
think so something to do with that
um and uh we did alec baldwin's podcast
uh on the patreon
we talked a little bit about that a
charming engaging fellow who reached out
and had me on honored
to be on the alec baldwin podcast at
such an important time to show
solidarity with a long island legend
uh alec baldwin truly because he's being
attacked
he's being there it's a pylon
and it is
cancel culture
that is i believe what he believes it is
and
i'm taking his word for it
he did have an incident
what are you gonna do
this is a
the world is complex
i don't think you could say
that the guy
wanted
what happened
to have happened
he was on set
somebody put a bullet and a gun
he shot a gun
a woman lost her life
this is not
anybody's
goal this wasn't anybody's goal
this was something that happened now you
might say why is he back to podcasting
so quickly or working but he's got to
work
he's got to work
what's he going to do
he's probably facing a lot of lawsuits
i don't think he'll be charged
criminally but there's probably some
lawsuits
and he may have to pay some money
so
he's gonna work
and we talk about that he has me on his
show and it comes out and we'll see
i don't always agree with what alec
baldwin does i seldom do
you know i mean he behaves in
some interesting ways but he is a
charming
engaging
fun guy
and in a world where we've
lost fun
uh
he's fun
he's a lot of fun
there's
many opinions about him and his
activities
but one thing he is
is a good
time
and that'll come out i don't know when
it'll come out we don't know no one
knows and
hopefully uh his situation gets
straightened out
and everybody can move on because it's a
tragedy and a woman lost her life and
you know
you know it's um
[Music]
bad
another thing that we
is bad right now is what's going on with
spotify
we've been following this everybody in
our business has been following this
over the past week
spotify is in a heated battle they're
embroiled in a major controversy
because they are hosting
right now
exclusively
the biggest podcast in the world
kill tony
and
tony hinchcliffe if you remember had an
incident
a few months ago where he's had a few
choice words for an asian opener of his
as a joke as a bit
and he's become one of the biggest media
stories in the world neil young
and joni mitchell have pulled their
music off spotify because they continue
to host kill tony the biggest and most
influential podcast in the world
tony hinchcliffe has uploaded videos to
his
instagram
trying to clarify some of his positions
and uh apologizing for past use of the
n-word
and spotify the ceo daniel eck has said
we are standing behind
tony hinchcliffe
and kill tony
why are you laughing
what why i mean it's a serious situation
no i know i'm i'll be i'll be serious i
don't know why you're laughing
i thought it was something totally
different what are you i thought you
were doing a bit but what do you mean
it's different i thought that spotify
was hosting the biggest podcast in the
world which is the joe rogan experience
and joe rogan used uh some choice words
on uh in the past 12 years of the show
and they made a compilation
uh this uh musician india ari
put a compilation out on twitter she put
the compilation out yeah it's it doesn't
look good it's him did she make it uh no
this has been on the internet so this
has to do with joe rogan
yes
is his show bit even big
it's up there
is it as big as kill tony uh well
spotify acquired the joe rogan
experience for like a hundred million
dollars well then how much did tony
hinchcliffe get
how much money did they have
i don't think they're doing great
so you're telling me this whole
controversy is about joe rogan
and not tony hinchcliffe's uh kill tony
yeah out of context him saying the n
word repeatedly in a 30-second thing
well i know that folks
this is a bit
i'm aware of that
who knows more about that than me
i know about that
but what i did was i threw your red
herring
to keep it interesting
some of you maybe don't know what's
going on you were led down another path
but that's not the accurate path
it is about joe rogan's show
you
know he's got powerful enemies a lot of
people dislike him
and a lot of people don't like that he
has 11 million people listening to him
and a lot of people would love him to be
de-platformed
and they want to get rid of him
and those people probably some of them
are in the white house
some of them are in congress
some of them
have a lot of money
they're in the private sector
some of them are celebrities and
musicians
and
i believe this is somewhat coordinated
to a degree
not
i'm not overly paranoid about this
but i do believe there's some effort
there's a push
to get rid of joe
any way they can
whether whether it's he's a racist
without any evidence
he's transphobic no
evidence he's um
anti-vaxx
a little evidence
tiny bit but not all of the vaxxes he's
had some conversations about this
particular one and on the third dose
when israel has been dosing people there
are three or four doses in and they've
got the highest rate of omicron in the
world the idea that the vaccine has
worked
as well as we wanted it to when it comes
to preventing transmission
it is not controversial to say
that it hasn't
it certainly seems to have kept people
out of the hospital which is great but
the idea that it's worked exactly as
planned that it's gone exactly as
planned
isn't true
and joe's had a few people on the show
to uh discuss it and those episodes have
gotten millions and millions tens of
millions of views
and people are upset and neil young and
joni mitchell
nils lofgren guitarist for the e street
band or springsteen that's right uh
india ari david crosby kind of
i don't know if he even owns his music
or not uh mary trump as well mary trump
roxanne gay
writer and podcaster roxy they've all
said let's get our music off spotify
because we want to take a stand
with
uh
the people that
these
people that wrote that letter the
scientists and the doctors who when you
look into it aren't all practicing
doctors but they wrote a letter saying
that's disadvantage
it's
disinformation
and you're allowing it to happen you're
allowing people to speak in a room and
you're allowing other people to listen
to it jen saki who's the white house
communications director
uh do you have a clip of this which
jen saki
literally goes they need to do more
they should go spotify needs to do more
to kick the guy off
this is the white house
press secretary
telling a private company
she
she would like
well the white house feels it's their
position
that a private company should do more to
censor
and maybe ultimately get rid of
uh a podcaster on their platform
this is uh
i guess it's somewhat unprecedented i
can't remember this happening before
it's a somewhat unique situation but i
know that you know the fcc had their
problems with howard stern and rush
limbaugh and
or people always wanted them off the air
and people have always wanted everybody
off the air
but this seems like a unique situation
where you can kind of
you know these musicians are in a unique
position to squeeze
spotify
and pressure spotify
uh so now there's disclaimers on
episodes that come out
um and i believe joe said he's gonna
work work to have some more
neutral or uh you know some more
opposite viewpoints
if he has somebody that's critical of
the vaccine
he's gonna have somebody on the other
side of that who
is pro-vaccine he said that in his video
that he uploaded to instagram
about this he's in a [ __ ] storm
he's in the middle of a [ __ ] storm
people are coming at him from all angles
in all directions they all have an
agenda
and he's trying to navigate and do the
best he can he's the biggest
one of the biggest entertainers on earth
now he's completely transcended the
world of comedy he's one of the most
famous people on the planet
there are
leaders of foreign countries tweeting
about this
it is a national news story for over a
week
every day
the white house is weighing in
uh it is so
big and i am so incredibly jealous
of this
i am so incredibly jealous of this man
and his ability to continually be in the
news
i what would i have to do
to get
anything
on this level
i mean i have chased
my whole entire [ __ ] career
the type of attention that he is getting
right now
and it's impossible for someone like me
to get
they won't even let me get big enough to
be hated and attacked
it's the one thing i've always wanted to
be threatened by the white house press
secretary to be de-platformed to have
roxane gay pull her podcast off spotify
because of me
and i can't it doesn't happen
i want jair bolsonaro tweeting that i'm
doing the right thing
and it's it's i'm i'm in a fit of
jealous rage
at this publicity it's amazing
his ability to just keep
what should i do i'll go out and say
cancer's not real
tell me what to do to get this level of
publicity i'll say aids was good
tell me what to do
i'll say being gay is a choice
i'll say abortion uh people that have
them should be
hung in a public square
what can i do
i don't even think it's that [ __ ]
controversial to say that the vaccines
didn't work that well
but that seems that's i guess the ticket
yeah that's what draws you the ire of
all of civilization
everybody gets mad and they only want to
talk about you
they only want to talk about him now
it's all about him
what about me
what about others
where is the oxygen left to discuss my
progress how well i've done the
followers we're getting the show that
we've built our massive stature on
patreon where is our [ __ ] storm
where are our meetings with lawyers
where are our tense late night
conversations where are my apology
videos
i'm left out
[ __ ] over
again
i mean
that's my takeaway
from this
that's my frustration here
do you understand
hassan [ __ ] buys a car and it's your
trends on twitter five days
i've bought multiple cars and crashed
them
i've lived in five houses in the last
year
what's the problem
now do you have this jen saki clip i
gave you enough time yes uh it's a new
york post one could you pull that up can
you pull that up thanks natalie thank
you natalie oh no the the new york post
one that i sent the most recent
if you refresh the email
thank you how do we get a how do we get
onto how do we get on the board here
christ
every day
i'm just in the background like a
nothing
just some piece of [ __ ] who puts on a
wig and says he's a dead senator's
daughter
can we get a little volume does the
volume come with it or is that sorry
thank you
i don't know if it comes with the rental
fee of the studio
maybe extra that's okay
guess
digitalnetwork.com folks a lot of fun
shows there
keeps offers a simple affordable and
stress-free way to keep your hair via
convenient virtual doctor consultations
and medications delivered straight to
your door every three months you don't
have to leave your home 24 7 care and
support keeps as a network of expert
medical advisors prescribers and care
specialists to support you in making
your hair goals a reality this is the
great way to keep the hair that you have
on your head on your head two out of
three men are going to experience some
form of hair loss by the time they're
whoever gives a [ __ ] keeps is everything
you need to keep the hair on your head
prevention is key treatments can take
four to six months to see results so act
fast you're fighting against the clock
when it comes to your hair save more and
spend less
keeps is cheaps
that's mine that's not even from the
script i'm adding that if you're ready
to take action and prevent hair loss go
to
k-e-e-p-s eps.com
tim dillon to receive your first month
of treatment for free baldi that's
k-e-e-p-s
dot com tim dylan to get your first
month free
k-e-e-p-s
slash tim dylan keeps just gave me 700
to do their new theme song and we're
debuting it right now
keeps is the cheapest way to keep your
hair on your head put your hand on your
head
ben loves it lucy nicotine lazages this
is the way to enjoy nicotine or relax
quit smoking you can enjoy them anywhere
at the office on a plane you don't smell
like smoke nobody knows you're doing it
tell the personal story
i wanted to start smoking again when you
uh told me to i was gonna direct your
special right because it's stressful and
you're gonna [ __ ] up uh potentially yeah
and it would all be my fault well we
don't want that even though there's many
people working on it i feel like it
would fall on me no i have all full
faith in you but uh but i have more
faith than lucy
this is the cinnamon flavor which i
really like but it's fun i haven't
smoked in almost three weeks now why
because of this gum oh my god it
satiates the need for a cigarette i have
to read this disclaimer warning this
product contains nicotine nicotine is an
addictive chemical
but we're adults here remember if you're
interested in a better way to use
nicotine visit lucy.co
and be sure to use the promo code tim
that is lucy dot co promo code tim and
you like ben avery will not need a siggy
seen comments uh on spotify and he said
that tech companies have an important
role to play in stopping this
information because the uh they are the
predominant places where misinformation
spreads um spotify is putting out uh
advisory warnings on episodes that have
to do with kobe 19. does the white house
and the administration think this is a
satisfactory step or do you uh do you
think that companies like spotify should
go further than just you know putting a
label on there to say hey go do your own
you know check this out you know there's
more research you can look at you know
scientific research regarding copenhagen
sure well last july
you probably know but the surgeon
general also took the unprecedented step
to issue an advisor on the risk of
misinformation in public health which is
a very significant step this woman's
very nice that he talked about the role
social media platforms have so our hope
is that all major tech platforms and all
major news sources for that matter be
responsible and be vigilant to ensure
the american people have access to
accurate information on something as
significant as covid19 that certainly
includes spotify so this disclaimer it's
a positive step but we want every
platform to continue doing more to call
misinform and miss and disinformation
while also uplifting accurate
information i mean look at the facts
right you are 16 times more likely to be
hospitalized if you're unvaccinated and
68 times more likely to die than someone
who is boosted if you're unvaccinated
that's pretty significant and we think
that is something that unquestionably
should be the basis of how people are
communicating about it but ultimately uh
you know our view is it's a it's a it's
a good step it's a positive step but
there's more that can be done
more that can be done jan saki the white
house going
more that can be done
what a pale woman very pale
it's uncomfortable when someone's that
pale you can see their veins
you could see the blood running through
their veins or lack thereof
um they want to do more well what what
what would be more
jen
they've got a disclaimer for the adults
if you're a child
and you somehow get on spotify should we
put a child lock on the phone
there's already they have that right
don't they have an app yeah yeah sure
they have an app protecting the children
from spotify
because you know the kids they want to
listen to robert malone for three hours
young impressionable uh teenagers they
want to listen to robert malone on joe
rogan so it's a real danger now adults
who are no long are not responsible for
their behavior anymore they don't if
you're an adult now whatever you do or
don't do faxed or unvaxed dead or alive
fat is thin
on fentanyl or not
whatever you're doing at any given
moment of the day is no longer your
responsibility it's because some
podcaster [ __ ] you over
some podcaster said something and you
took it to heart and now you made a
choice that got you killed because you
listen to a podcaster because that's
where you get your information from
you're an adult in america and you have
to be protected from people that put on
headphones and talking to a mic two or
three times a week because they
uh are your only sole source of
information
and uh they'll get you killed
these podcasts are dangerous they'll get
you killed
apparently
you just start dropping dead people are
dropping like flies they listen to a
podcast and they go oh well that guy
made a good point i'm gonna do that and
then you die
that's what happens you die because you
listen to what the podcaster said
so
uh
jen saki this pale woman from the white
house and joe biden who's not making
statements and we don't know where he is
but our totally okay healthy
a feral
focused president joe biden
unable to pass the bill back better act
makes very few public appearances
the corpse the skin suit
joe biden
okay
the guy
who like designed the 94 crime bill
okay
that worked out well for people of color
uh that guy and jensac he wants spotify
to do more because the last thing god
forbid an adult
listens to a conversation that they
can't handle
they hear it and they go i gotta do what
that guy
because that's the way people behave i
guess
i don't know
that's the way people behave people uh
behave that way
well
what are you gonna do
people behave that way they can't
they can't be trusted to understand and
deal with the information that they get
and
go and find other sources of information
maybe people's decision making is
complex
maybe they make decisions for many
different reasons
maybe there are many variables to their
decision making
perhaps
maybe adults
have many different
rationalizations
justifications
for any
single decision they make
whether it's to get vaccinated or not
get vaccinated
whether it's to be healthy or not be
healthy whether it's to use drugs
and
alcohol whether it's to be respectful of
women
or other races or gay people or trans
men whatever you decide to do with your
life and hey maybe it is uh more than a
podcast
that uh gets you to that point perhaps
maybe speculating merely speculating
that
people out there
are
perhaps motivated by several different
factors you can't hang it all on a one
guy
who did a few episodes
you can't hang it all on one dude
especially when the thing started and
trump goes here's the vaccine and the
democrats go i'm not trusting that i
don't want that that was a that was a
little quick wasn't it
and then uh they kicked trump out that
binds and then they go the vaccine's
great we love it
take it you don't get uh you won't get
it you take it you got it
okay well you're full of acts you won't
get it uh uh you got it but you won't
get sick you'll be asymptomatic well now
you're sick
well you're not gonna spread it well you
spread it so it's like kinda and by the
way the fight is over no one cares
anymore you're either vaxxed and boosted
it's over it's it's done now
studies are coming out saying natural
immunity lasts 18 months
people are done you know the uk just
opened up can you bring this up the uk
that rainy hell where they eat fish
pudding is ahead of us they've opened up
i think with nothing no mandates nothing
they're free
yeah mask rules everything mask rules
all of it's done and the idea that we're
still in this heated debate about
vaccines we're not it's been settled so
this attack on joe i don't think is
about that i don't really think it's
about that i think it's about we don't
want this guy around
for the midterms for the next election
we just don't like him in general we
don't like that somebody's got this
level of power
and we're gonna go find everything he
said he's a comedian who's talked into a
microphone for 12 years we're going to
find everything he said
um and he does this whole thing with the
n-word
and i'm gonna say nutella
instead of what it is
he has said nutella
a lot of times on his podcast he was
quoting other people who used the word
nutella he never called a nutella a
nutella
he never did that he never said hey
you're a nutella he never did that
he said
the word nutella is interesting you know
how he does um
nutella man
it's an interesting word man
because some people can use it
and it's fine
but then other people say nutella and
they're racist and it's bad
and he was quoting people who had used
the word nutella now we all know
nutella's a no no you don't say nutella
there's a compilation of him where it's
literally nutella nutella nutella
nutella nutella nutella nutella nutella
and and sometimes nutella
a lot of the times it's nutella
which is worse than nutella because
nutella is like hey nutella but nutella
is a bad one and they're all bad
and i don't use that word i say nutella
so
and then he did something where he went
to go see the movie planet of the apes
and he got out of a car
and he was in an area where there was
a lot of uh
african-american people
and he said hey it really looks like
planet of the apes here uh and he said
it looks like we're in africa and again
it's a he made a joke it was an
off-color joke
and
people flipped out about it they're
trying to people make racial jokes
people do it all the time people make
jokes about blacks and jews and puerto
ricans and
other races too
people [ __ ] on russians
catholics
irish italians
finnish dutch
why not mexicans
el salvadorians
armenians
white people
like ben
from some dust bowl [ __ ] nowhere place
people have all these jokes uh koreans
japanese asians chinese everybody has
jokes
about different races because the races
are different
you see
now we're all human beings we're all the
same
oh
what was that where was that
what's that
she's calling you
no no not that not that no we can't do
that i sent the planet of the apes clip
right now kick us off youtube yeah
we make a lot of money we're not like
the people in this studio we make real
money here please
we have to take a note of that no no i i
get listen we got real money i love
these people but no we're not come on
now we can't she just started to play
the nutella clip
she's a sweet woman but i mean they're
going to kick us off this would this
would scroll up daddy honey we've got
things to lose natalie scroll up this
planet of the apes uh clip is what i was
talking about here yeah yeah let's not
even play this guys
why keep spreading
whatever
he's explained it it's enough already
yeah my point
let's go back to me
my point is that people make fun of
races all the time it's not a big deal
it's not a huge deal depends on your
intent
people do it all the time racial humor
you know nobody's ever worked a [ __ ] low
wage job
i've worked a lot of [ __ ] low-wage jobs
at different races that make fun of each
other every day because it's a fun way
to meet make new friends
now people that go to harvard don't do
that people that write blogs they go to
these [ __ ] liberal arts schools i suck
[ __ ] i can say it and
those people don't ever do those types
of jokes because they don't they don't
really like dark humor or gallows humor
or racial humor because they don't need
to because they're privileged pieces of
[ __ ] so they like very like you know
urbane
sardonic kind of like unfunny
uh you know reporte
and it's very
they're very careful not to offend
anyone but in a lot of [ __ ] jobs i've
worked or people weren't making a lot of
money people like to joke around about
stuff and it's funny
it's fun we used to work with a ton of
muslims
and it was a black guy once and this one
of our supervisors was a muslim woman
and he said uh she was mad at him
because he was late and he got man she
gonna blow the bus up it's funny
it's fi relax
no one cares
this is 5 000 people on twitter care
no one cares it's not a big deal there's
you pick and choose your moments
you can get punched if you do the wrong
racial joke in the wrong setting
it's not a good idea to just start
throwing words out there but just the
general idea of different races uh no
listen racial humor is also a little
antiquated it's a little older people
have moved on i don't really do any of
it in my act i i mean i have a joke
about saudis and but it's funny and it's
like but the vast majority of it yeah
time moves on
people move on people evolve things
evolve
but racial humor in and of itself
doesn't make people racist
right
it it doesn't just make people that do
jokes about gay people doesn't mean they
hate gay people
but we're living in a society now where
everything's literal
because people
have lost their minds they've forgotten
the point of humor
which is to make this hellish experience
a little better
a little lighter and a little more fun
so
i saw the nutella clip and i understand
why people got angry about it but they
need to relax
they could release a clip where he says
[ __ ] a million times
uh what am i supposed to do it hurt me
i'm hurt in my life
ah i got
my life
if someone on the internet
says something and it really hurts
and
angers you
you're a loser
i don't know what to tell you
if somebody on the internet
can get to you that deeply and it it's
not about you
it's not about your family they're not
threatening to kill you
they said a word you didn't like and you
don't even know the context that they
said it if it really sits with you
like if it could be a mild annoyance you
could turn it off i don't like that but
if it really sits with you where you
just can't get on with your day and it's
really i think you got to look at the
life you're living
and go
why am i letting people affect me like
this why am i letting a guy who's using
a word
in context
it doesn't mean it's the right word to
use in that context i don't know all the
context but why am i letting it why does
it bother me why do i get angry about
something like that
you could play [ __ ] compilations all
day
i don't it doesn't bother me because i
have things to do
do you understand
i got [ __ ] to do
i'm not sitting there
you know
going that person
doesn't think i'm a human being i don't
care
stop caring
what's wrong with you people
you know short life is stop caring stop
being invested in what strangers think
or what words they say
it's silly
what a horrible way to live you'll be
miserable every day of your life without
fail
if you just get offended in everything
people say
they say to you it's a different story
if they say it about you
it's a different story if they're using
this word
i'm not saying you should celebrate it
i'm not saying you should go good job
i'm saying you should walk the other way
like online
you ignore it
because they'll face consequences
usually for it
or they'll evolve and stop using it or
they'll continue to use it and you won't
be affected at all
because you have a good life that you've
created that has nothing to do with them
that might be a good way to do it
you've got back-to-back meeting errands
to run chores to take care of what's the
secret to clearing your to-do list a
little help from doordash you can get
dinner household essentials and
everything on your grocery list
delivered ever pull into the driveway
after a trip to the grocery store only
to realize you forgot that one key
ingredient for dinner now you have
options get the groceries you need or a
backup meal from your favorite local
restaurant delivered with doordash what
do you want to eat tonight maybe a
home-cooked favorite but you don't feel
like going to the store or you want
something exciting and new but it would
be great to stay in doordash connects
you with everything you want whenever
and however you want it it's time to get
back out there but if you're not quite
ready for a full-blown adventure there's
still ways to explore the world from the
comfort of your home
with doordash you don't need to travel
far to experience something new get what
you want to eat right now right to your
door with doordash i love have you used
doordash yeah i got thai food the other
day oh it's great you can get groceries
you can get prepared meals ordering is
easy it's easy
children can do it my friend's baby does
it
why he's a baby
and we make him order doordash for
everybody
and sometimes because he's trolling us
he'll just order cleaning products it's
like a big joke
for a limited time our listeners can get
25 off and zero delivery fees on their
first order of 15 or more when you
download the doordash app and enter code
tim dillon
download the app enter code tim dillon
that's 25 off up to a 10 value and zero
delivery fees on your first order when
you download the doordarshan the app
store and enter code tim dillon that's
don't forget that's code
t-i-m-d-i-l-l-o-n tim dillon for 25 off
your first order with doordash subject
subject to change terms apply
me undies oh man
i love me undies they're the best
underwear do you like me undies i'm
wearing them right now they're amazing
me undies makes the softest fabric
you'll ever put on your body so you can
sit on your couch all day or go out and
live your comfiest life once you try
their undies socks bralettes and
loungewear you'll never go back choose
from a range of limited edition prints
and colors in sizes from extra small to
4xl you can also sign up for their free
to join me undies membership where you
get a monthly subscription that sends
new styles right to your door well that
sounds like a good idea plus enjoy
discounted pricing free shipping and
exclusive early access to new launches
they are the most comfortable underwear
on the market it's a fact
everybody knows it and if you order with
our promo code you're going to get 15
off how cool is that awesome it's a fun
way it's more than awesome
it's a fun way to support the show and
it's a great way to get the most
comfortable underwear at a discount
15 off your first order and free
shipping
free
go to meundies.com
tim that's meundies.com
tim get the most comfortable
products on the market they have their
promise if you're not satisfied with any
product for any reason you can return
your order for a full refund within 45
days but nobody does that because these
are the best underwear
it's true everybody loves them nobody
has a bad thing to say about me undies i
have them you have them everybody has
them
dogs and cats wear them in new york
that's how comfortable they are and
you'd think dogs and cats wouldn't wear
them because they're made of fur you go
oh they'd already be comfortable no
me undies is so comfortable that even
animals wear them
meundies.com t-i-m let's talk about this
professor at nyu he came out hard for
pedophilia and it's uh
it
sometimes when people say this they go
so they're trying to normalize
pedophilia you go oh
maybe we're exaggerating right
this doesn't seem
to be an exaggeration this guy
goes full bore here
and the quotes are crazy they're insane
and he's from the state university of
new york state university he's under a
review or something yeah yeah his name
is stephen
on twitter turn me on this you follow
her no no human trafficking advocate
uh let me get a twitter handle she's a
fun follow
and uh
you know she covers a topic that a lot
of people don't it's
blue bl eu like blue cheese i also like
to cheat that's her name
and she's a human trafficking survivor
and she advocates on behalf of victims
and she compiles news that a lot of
people don't care about like missing
kids and [ __ ] like that um and then this
guy
uh this professor kind of goes
he goes off the deep end and i hate to
laugh at this because it's really
horrible
but you can only kind of chuckle at
someone's insanity
at
doing this but for 25 years
quotes of the article absolutely yeah
yeah these are the direct quotes
from the uh state university of new york
professor
uh stephen uh kirschner whatever he
teaches libertarian philosophy and
applied ethics there you go libertarian
philosophy
no driver's licenses private roads and
then eventually
you know so imagine that an adult male
wants to have sex with a 12 year old
girl imagine that she's a willing
participant
a very standard very widely held view is
that there's something deeply wrong
about this and it's wrong independent of
it being criminalized it's not obvious
to me that it's in fact wrong
i think this is a mistake and i think
exploring that why it's a mistake will
tell us not only things about adult sex
and statutory rape and also fundamental
principles of morality
he goes on to say let me scroll down
here uh he says fun class huh
what class was this even was he you know
what i mean like where did he just break
it where did he just go into this uh one
of some of these quotes are from a
podcast he did with some guy and the
guy's like agreeing it's always the
podcasts
that get everybody in trouble
so in one of the clips he says no one
cares about this right right
he goes one is even if you're looking
for a threshold let's say there's a
threshold i'm making this number up but
let's just say it's at age eight still
that tells you that some adult sex is
perfect what's interesting is rogan is
having this guy on tomorrow and that's
what i respect about joe fly into the
storm keep going
okay
uh
uh second the notion that it's wrong
even with a one-year-old is not quite
obvious to me
there are reports in some cultures of
grandma's uh fellating their boys to
calm them down if they're colicky i
don't know if this is true but this is
sort of a widely reported as occurring
in at least a foreign culture and it
working that the grandmas believe that
this actually works
yeah well there's this guy and he is uh
employed at the state university of new
york and again it's yeah i'm not a
cancer culture person but i will say
that is certainly
a position to take it is this is
probably it seems evil if you're gonna
give him a strong argument here's
probably his strongest argument right
here
okay so he makes an odd comparison of
yonder's youngsters taking part in
athletic activities he says
they might think that children can't be
willing things in general it's an odd
view and that they seem to will things
all the time they will participation in
kickball
they will be showing up and
participating in bar mitzvah lessons bad
mitzvah lessons he says you might think
well maybe there's something distinct
about sex that they can't really
understand it it's not clear to me that
what they're not getting at is consent
so that's kind of his uh well i don't
know that that's a great argument
benjamin um he says i suspect that uh
what they want to say is that they're
willing participants they're voluntary
they play kickball
what's the problem well that's a fun
professor
what are you going to rape my professor
is that one of those
you know my professor was fun but then
he started talking about [ __ ]
eight-year-olds and it got a little
weird
he's real cool
doesn't care about lateness not a
stickler on note-taking but i'll tell
you right now when he starts going off
about the kids
it gets a little weird
well
odd
odd odd odd
that these are opinions that are
are happening and uh you know they're
out there and it's um
it's uh rather disturbing we're on the
road by the way i want to talk about
this a little bit we're shooting a
special in denver
uh um march 26th at the paramount
theater
and ben is going to direct it so if it
looks like [ __ ] it's his fault
penn's never really directed anything
before except all of the videos we've
done but you've never done any
comedy specials right no never shot a
comedy special this will be your first
time that's right do you feel any
pressure tons yeah you should feel tons
of pressure yeah you shouldn't sleep i
the first when you asked me to do it i
didn't really sleep the first day yeah i
was very nervous well i you should be
very nervous but i didn't start smoking
again so that's well that's good
congratulations but we're concerned with
the results of the special
whatever substances
you uh are partaking of are of no
concern to me our concern only again is
with the results of the special which
you are doing uh for the first time we
have a lot of faith in you thank you i
stand by you
like daniel eck
i don't care what others say about you
i stand by you
we will my skin is so [ __ ] it's from
the cold in new york it just feels like
it's gonna fall off my face
um we're shooting it on march 26th
and
then we're done then we've got some new
uk dates that have just been rescheduled
where we're going to ireland
london
and glasgow scotland
and we're doing those dates that we're
done we're off the road for a while
we're focusing on the podcast and some
other things
that we have planned some cool [ __ ]
that we're gonna do let's talk about
some of these dates just do it quickly
where are we gonna be phoenix this
weekend february 10th through the 12th
you know i love that you know what i
love about arizona what's that is that
it's so horrible
uh those are almost sold out
not all of it
not all of it but enough of it
is horrible
but not every part i like scottsdale
where else am i going to be uh then
you're going to the tampa theater in
tampa florida february 17th that's a
thursday you know what's good about
tampa everybody goes tampa's next it
ain't
but i like tampa because it feels
there's a great sexual energy there's a
lot of strip clubs and sex shops and
it's always sweltering hot
and people are down to [ __ ] on the west
coast of florida it just is what it is
in that sense there's sexual energy in
tampa i would even say it's a little you
know miami has like that whole it's very
sexy overtly but tampa has an
underground kind of sex dungeon feel
that i like to consensual dungeon lock
yourself in
um
tampa theater and we are excited to be
down there and you go right over to
orlando orlando's fun because we're
doing the disney theater the disney
theater in orlando and i have a lot to
say about disney uh that'll be february
18th then uh february 20th in uh san
antonio texas at the majestic now san
antonio what's fun about that is it is
one of the fattest cities in america
people are truly four to eight hundred
pounds any one of them um they they are
the size of cars
and they move
uh like
cattle the way they just kind of get in
there
and i like that that to me is good and
i'm i enjoy that and they have great
mexican food
and everything you eat there just
explodes in your stomach you just get
every meal you get fatter in san antonio
you never get smaller you just expand
like a hot air balloon until you
eventually can't fit in your car then
you got to get a bigger car and then you
got to get a bigger car and then you die
but i like san antonio so buy tickets to
the show
then you're heading to uh portland maine
on february 25th we're not really
selling well in portland maine i'm going
to be very honest with you a lot of
people aren't buying tickets in portland
maine and part of the reason is that all
the men in portland maine most of them
have vaginas
um it is a very confused place
uh portland maine
is for you know it's a kind of the worst
people in the world it's very very
left-wing in a very annoying way there's
only 50 000 people that live there it's
devoid of any culture [ __ ] your lobster
roll shove it up your ass it's devoid of
any culture i'd rather be in kenny
bunkport performing for the bushes at a
human sacrifice than going to [ __ ]
portland and entertaining these [ __ ]
substitute teachers socialist losers but
it's what i have to do because we were
doing it to be in conjunction with i
didn't go i want to go to portland maine
we were in toronto and my uh agent
faticus finch
was trying to find gigs that
would go around toronto so we found
portland maine
and i was a little maybe confident that
certain people in portland maine would
enjoy
uh fun
but we've uh uh figured out here that
portland maine
uh you know it's a 2 000 seat theater
and what have we sold can you get the
numbers up yeah let me get the they got
500 tickets i mean it's a abominable
it is an appalling
showing in portland maine
because um
let's see so they hate me portland maine
uh we have uh uh 533 of the 1900 sold
533 tickets sold of 1900
so i i don't know what we're gonna do
here can we bus in people that live
outside of portland maine to go see the
show should i start paying for
transportation
maine is uh you know it's uh
it's a lot of blue lip fentanyl addicts
peeling potatoes
and then you also have the the rich
lobster people on but other than that
there's not much going on over there
everybody there is is is fentanyl white
meaning just chen sake white kind of
pale ghostly
and they have chapped blue lips and they
just want to take a couple of pills and
fall on the floor
and i understand that but they're not
coming out to see the comedy show and it
makes me very upset
makes me very sad
um
so please
if you can
buy tickets to the show in portland
maine because i don't want to be there
but i have to be legally i'm
contractually obligated to uh uh be
there what can we look up portland maine
what has anything been invented in
portland maine has anything come out of
portland
i
much rather portland oregon
the rainy
uh uh thai food antifa stronghold on the
west coast i actually loved it there the
audiences were great and if i dye my
hair pink i'll have three to five blocks
under my control by midnight tonight
i like that it's a fun city
uh we got a the machine gun
the machine gun came out of portland
maine well don't bring any of those
uh the zigzag stitch
oh
okay which is a sewing related invention
between right okay uh earmuffs
earmuffs oh farmington man i can't claim
that to portland but yeah whatever
uh and it seems the oven came from maine
too so and the seal dive suit
the sealed dive suit you know the dive
suit with the big uh big helmet yes
great
buy the tickets to the [ __ ] shell
please because otherwise i'm gonna look
like an idiot
where else uh then you go right to
providence rhode island
providence rhode island i like white
people who struggle
and providence great italian food great
old mob town again heroin horror dark
bleak decrepit decaying all the things
that are requirements to really enjoy a
dose of my outlook and world view for an
hour are present in providence that is
good i like property don't clean it up
before i get there that's always what i
say and they never do and never will
what's next you head over to a place
called the egg in albany
albany new york albany's uh nothing but
the egg is a great theater it's a great
theater now we are selling tickets there
so if you're in albany new york or god
help you in like troy or one of those
de-industrialized hellscapes that we've
allowed people to live in and fester
um while globalization has completely
destroyed and hollowed out their lives
and communities if you're one of those
people crawling on the floor of an old
house
you know
looking for pills it might have dropped
a few months ago
trying to find a stray vicodin on the
kitchen floor
heating up a 7-eleven dinner and you can
stick someone outside the mall
for 39.95
come on down to the show you're gonna
love it
it's for you
concord new hampshire february 27th
concord new hampshire
who even cares just buy the tickets uh
toronto
meridian march 16th the psychotic
government of canada is going to allow
us to do a show
in concord
new hampshire finally i mean no
i'm having a stroke
nutella
um
what's happening here
is that
we're able to do the show in toronto
finally we've had to move it twice
because they've cut the capacity and go
it's a big theater and they go you gotta
only have half the people like we can't
do that it's not fun
it sucks
so what we've been able to do finally is
get you know a show on in meridian hall
in toronto and there are still tickets
left for meridian hall toronto this is
the end of the tour this is it and then
we're done we go off the road
get it home in our beautiful new studio
which is great looks great
people love it
and then we're good to go we're able to
take a little break breathe focus on the
internet film some [ __ ] i'll get some
new material in the comedy clubs and
then maybe we'll tour i don't know later
my agent thinks the fall
i don't think i'll be ready by the fall
but
yeah it's like four months to get a new
hour yeah it's not gonna happen by the
fall but that's okay
whatever he can start a podcast
invest in yourself
move to austin
uh then you go to baltimore march 18th
baltimore march 18th let's get the
tickets going in baltimore too because i
do love baltimore i love the food i love
crab cakes and uh i'm a big fan of
baltimore dc i've performed there a lot
i did a lot of shows in maryland
uh i remember i did a show in anne
arundel maryland with this guy
and the mic was going
in and out there was this crazy guy
right
and we used to go on the road with him
and he brought us on the road to this
county anne arundel county in maryland
and
we're staying
at this guy's house or somebody he knew
and he he knew this guy
whose house we were staying at like some
friend he had there and we're staying
and the friend
had just broke up with his girlfriend
who lived across the street and she left
him and literally walked across the
street
and he was a very depressing guy
and it was very sad
and i was trying to make conversation
with him
later on
and i said
i was like hey dude and he was just
sitting there like kind of catatonic
through the whole comedy show which was
not going well it was in like this you
know vfw hall and this suburban maryland
and the only thing that was working was
like local jokes and one guy got up
there he's like yeah you ever been to
dundalk and everybody's like
but you know i'm up there and other
people are up there we're bombing and
it's you know thank god the guy did the
local job you need someone to do that
because
we were bombing and like the mic would
go out and then the mic would come back
on and the people look sad they go
they liked it the only laughs we got the
only smiles was when we were talking
into the mic and then trying to figure
out the mic and they went
because it was funny because they could
see
we were panicking we didn't know what to
do and that was funny to them because
they hated when the mic went on and they
could hear what we were saying
but when it went off and it kept going
off it was like a funny bit they might
have even thought oh this is the bit i
like this
good and then the mic would you know go
back on and they'd go well i don't like
this part of the bit
so there so i go sit down after my set
my set was one of those where's just
whoa you're sweating you're like this is
not good and you sit down and i turn
around to this guy
the friend of the guy that brought us to
the gig the guy that was staying at his
house the guy whose girlfriend left him
and walked across the street he sold
scoreboards to local high schools that
was his
job said i was trying to make
conversation i went hey
you've got waffle crisp and cinnamon
toast crunch in your house that's pretty
cool
and then you just look at me he turned
around and turned his head ever so
slightly to me
and he goes like this he goes
there's no milk
it's expired
[Laughter]
and then he just again catatonic just
straight on
watching another comedian fiddle with
this broken microphone
in suburban maryland
and that was my life for years
for years and years you would do things
like that and then you'd write a funny
facebook status about it
and everybody would go [ __ ] yeah man
that's great you're living like we met a
friend of mine from long island the
other day
he was very sweet great guy and i grew
up with these guys we're like best
friends and
just connecting with someone having a
lunch with them but everyone on long
island everything is so
tragic that no matter what anyone talks
about is like
very sad you'll be like you know
you know how's frank doing and he goes
oh frank's good
frank's good
frank and his wife when and they say it
so nonchalantly he goes you know frank
and his wife went on vacation in the
bahamas and she got a rare parasite she
actually had to have half of her stomach
removed so she can't really eat anymore
if she eats more than three bites of
anything she has like violent acid
reflux and she just starts to
aggressively burp so what they what
they're doing is they're bringing her in
for major surgery she's got to kind of
learn how to eat again like a child but
frank's doing great
and you go and you're eating you go
oh
he goes frank's doing great and he goes
you ever see sarah
sarah
sarah is as fun as ever
she met a guy and he died in a
motorcycle accident
he was her one true love they got
married two nights later he had a
massive relapse got on his bike and
killed himself
sarah's doing really good she's working
over at uh the grocery store
oh
the clams are good have you had the
have you tried the clams
the clams are very good
it's never-ending
uh
the hell
there but it's also very impressive the
way people just
handle it like la everyone's a [ __ ]
they can't handle anything
they can't handle a word that i don't
lie right now
these people are watching their friends
and family members die
in front of them every day in like final
destination ways nobody in long island
dies like a regular way these people are
dying of rare cancers
four car pileups construction accidents
rare diseases this wild [ __ ] and they're
just soldiering through it
and it's really impressive they're
soldiering through it you know and and
you soldier through the lunch
you you fight through that lunch because
it's you're getting the reality of what
it is you're getting the reality of what
it it's not what you'd want it to be
it's what it is and it was good to
connect with that person and hopefully i
see them again but it's like uh
you just got to be prepared for a gray
long island uh uh lunch over at the fish
hut
you go over to clam shack in the rain
and you're gonna get an earful and
you're just never quite prepared
oh yeah no michelle's good
michelle's doing really really good
she's on chemo now
and she has been for the last four
months it's not she's stage four and a
half
i'm like what stage four and a half
because that's when every day they do
last rites
so every day they come in and two last
rites expect you're gonna die but then
she'll live through the night and they
come and do it again so we've gone to
like seven vigils for her
we're expecting maybe next week but we
don't know
oh but she's i mean good spirits
great spirits
she looks great she's lost weight
you go oh
well that's nice
but it's good to reconnect with people
but it's also time to get the [ __ ] out
of here my flight was delayed again i'm
sending him to austin i'm staying here
another night going to see christos
stefano at the beacon theater did a fun
patreon episode with him patreon.com uh
the tim dillon show if you're interested
in any of the bonus content there or our
rothschild here are higher tier episode
with ray kump
our once a month video episode is out on
that as well
buy products
because that supports the show it helps
us out
when you have um
use the promo codes and buy the products
right oh we have a few more dates here
too when we read the book oh yeah for
the i'm just pitching products
i'm trying to pitch products
and the guy doesn't
they give him all the free [ __ ]
i don't need it
so he gets it him and the wife get all
the free stuff because they like
freebies
i do apologize on are you garb and this
is you know
i i was just showing off but on are you
garbage i told everybody how much i gave
you for your wedding oh nice i mean i i
it's i don't want to anger you because i
know you hate your money being out there
but it's really not about you it's more
about me
and it was a fun moment on are you
garbage but
it's it's not to offend you
it's not a lot of money in the way for
me or what i think but it's not too
effect are you offended
did you say the real answer what do you
mean on the podcast or did you do a joke
answer no i told the real answer oh you
did the real answer why how'd it come up
i think i think
you you they were asking what i give to
for people what do i give to people for
weddings
so i told them what i gave you
which i think is a nice amount
and i know that you get offended by that
right
aren't you offended by it uh slightly
yeah now why are you offended by it i i
mean it's not
it's just private right it's just a
private thing right do we not bleed for
the people
do we not bleed on the stage for the
people we do we do
our i guess it's fair our lives are in
the in the tabloids now nowadays i guess
are they in the tabloids well the new
tabloids are the the uh these sites like
reddit and these things
are they the new tabloids i suppose so
right really
hot take
finish the dates please
philadelphia pennsylvania at the parks
casino marching band casino you have fun
because it's a comedy and gambling
what's good is you you become a winner
you leave a winner
it's good come gamble a little bit uh
smoke drink make merry comedy show
whatever you want to do they pay you a
lot in casinos because they know you
people are going to come in and gamble
your hard-earned money away and then eat
cheesecake and go up to the room and do
drugs
uh then you're at the ryman auditorium
in nashville tennessee i'm an auditorium
auditorium in nashville i have been
excited about this show for a long time
i've said bad things about nashville
bygones
um i've said bad things about everywhere
new york la everything um what i what
i'm really excited about is this show
because they're great audiences down
there it's just a little too live laugh
love for me with the you know
everybody's a blonde with the ugg boots
and enough
but you know nashville i'm excited for
the show big time
uh then uh the special uh march 26th
two shows march 26th in denver two shows
and then what is the uh uh what is the
uk date new uk days i don't think those
have been uh
yeah but they'll be early april march 26
two shows tickets are really flying
people want to be involved ben avery
directing the special which will
probably go on youtube because netflix
is not buying anything maybe we'll put
it on
butterfly
what do you think about this spotify
controversy how does it end
how does it end
you're a mind
i guess it
statistically good job
ben avery everybody that's his take on
the spotify controversy and how it may
end
good way to phrase it he's got a good
turn of phrase and he's going places as
the kid
timdylandcomedy.com for all your needs
buy tickets in portland may not kill
myself
uh uh we'll be we'll be back soon alec
baldwin podcast coming out are you
garbage love those guys that's coming
out monday flagrant 2 is out right now
heading towards a million views
and uh
back to la soon maybe hassan park will
try to squeeze me in his porsche
good night